MAN: Wounded coming in.
MAN: All right, here we go.
All right.
[INAUDIBLE] I
can't rouse myself.
MAN: Take it through.
MAN: We don't got nowhere--
[CHATTER]
All right, Julian.
You can chain
him on the floor.
[CHATTER]
[SOBBING]
[LOCK CLICKS]
[CHAINS CLANK]
[GRUNTING]
What do they call you?
Thomas.
Do you have a family, Thomas?
A wife, someone to think about?
Mama?
Then remember, this is just
work, same as you always done,
just work.
God is with us.
How can you say that to him?
God is with us?
Where is he?
Like, why has he
not set you free?
Or has he?
You are not in these.
Well, then, stand up.
Stand up.
Go.
Stand up, and then praise
your God for all he has
done for you, for all of us.
You-- God is not with you.
He is nowhere.
He sends that fool to
tell us about his word,
to be a good slave, to be
obedient to your masters.
Is that what God says to you?
God says many things.
I do not know why.
God shows himself to some
people and not to others.
But if you do not know
him, I will pray for you.